why are you so important
somewhere out west
they're working on a cure I think what
really impressed them was the fact that
I didn't turn into a monster
okay first of all uh Bella Pedro
congratulations on the series it is
literally incredible I just spoke to
Craig and one of the things he remarked
on is he knew the chemistry between you
two had to be great and he said it was
instantaneous I'd really love for you to
talk about when y'all kind of knew that
this was gonna work the way it did in
the game and if there was any aspects of
the relationship in the game that you
thought would be key to what you guys
were doing in this one great question
um well yeah we just we met for the
first time just as I was getting my
haircut and you just come off set it was
a very like brief meeting we didn't have
like time to get to know each other and
and but yeah the chemistry it was just
immediately this Bond unspoken like
connection of like we're both embarking
on this huge journey together like as
Jordan Ellie but as two people as well
like suddenly we have we're spending a
year together in our birth to Canada
like not knowing what the hell we're
doing and we're just like having to
trust the trust the process but you know
what I mean like it it really was that
um I feel like there was all of this
kind of like little
unspoken
relationship developing even before we
got to Canada yeah like little like you
know we started following each other on
Instagram and starting to kind of like I
don't know I feel like sending little
signals I a little little signals to to
one another kind of you know shyly but
but the the excitement and the
anticipation was obviously so clear and
then I guess to avoid the pressure of of
what it would mean for this to work
between the two of us we just we're as
casual as we could be you came in for to
get your hair cut I was shooting and
then we and then the next and then the
first time we were together I was like
throwing you up against a wall yes and
um and holding a gun at you
um and I'm like hey what's up
several times yeah several times in the
show seriously in the script
absolutely
um I will say I would have said that you
two bonded over being fan favorite
characters on a little show elsewhere
just saying like an element you know
yeah I watched the show before I got on
that show and continued to watch it
after I departed and was able to meet
and fall in love with Lady Mormont
um like everyone else so yes I was a
little Fanboy don't even tell don't even
say that you watched my season I didn't
I get my teeth punched out my eyes
squished in in my head
you might like it based on what you said
I don't want to get out of here though
without getting this in there really
quickly I know both of you are not maybe
like diving into the game like I was and
playing it two times through but you
have to know what the clicker scene
means anybody that knows anything about
that and having that in the trailer what
was it like for you guys how much did
you know what you were going up against
would look like did they do that
practically or did you really just have
to imagine it it was a little practical
it was very practical it was too
practical practical
um yeah I I didn't I didn't I knew that
they were gonna pull something really
brilliant out of the Hat as far as that
was concerned but I didn't expect it to
be
as real looking on the day and
um and and some things sometimes you
know the opportunity for everything to
be at your disposal in that way and to
to immerse you into the experience to to
to to to to shoot the story but
sometimes some things are better left to
the imagination because
that was very
disturbing is her birth
giddy up giddy up they looked really
scary I they were scary in the show when
you talking about it's like it's it's
very scary on the show I know we're used
to it but it's not like it's less also
Pedro I definitely want to talk about
this because I just think it's really
cool that you know whatever with Mando
protection I mean there's a little solo
man on a mission maybe cutting himself
off from the world is this you
therapizing on screen I'm just curious
It's too similar not to at least remark
on it I guess it is you know I didn't
even realize it until now really
um it is like the the the most uh the
most special double dip that I could
possibly uh have experienced
um where where they are so similar and
so different and and and and and it's
just been like amazing to step into
those shoes and that armor I'll take you
with me
say what I said
get any advice on the best way west
yeah go east
Merle Neil it is great uh to see you all
I will say that uh you already have a
debt of many of my hours as I played the
game I think it's many hours for way too
long but I'll start with you Neil um
you've said that the show allowed you to
include a lot of things that you
couldn't and maybe do some things that
maybe at the time of the first game or
even in the remaster you couldn't talk
about some of these new places you got
to explore with this different medium
the big the biggest difference I think
for me is in the game one the game has
to support A Lot More Action I think
than is required in the show for the
sake of gameplay right you have to
there's a certain Mastery that comes
with the game that once you do have that
Mastery there's this Bond you feel with
the playable character that's very
unique to games that we knew for that's
the strength of the game and we
shouldn't try to replicate that in the
show so with the show what we can do is
leave Joel and Ellie's perspective and
really focus on these other characters
and get to flesh them out and by
fleshing them out it makes their
interactions with Joel Nelly that much
richer so for example like we get to see
Marlene what what is she struggling with
right because
um there's certain goals that she wants
that are has an inner conflict with what
she feels is right and wrong and she has
to sacrifice her own morality to kind of
achieve these goals
um likewise there's all the like the
character of David and like these other
things that we get to show the humanity
of the antagonist the quote unquote
again there was no real villain in this
story there's just people with competing
goals and then there are some other just
like other stories that were written
since the game has come out for
different projects that for one reason
or another didn't didn't happen that um
you know when Craig and I started
talking about the story and kind of
breaking it down I mentioned some of
those to him and he was just wide eyes
and like like a fan he was excited like
oh my God we got a visual we gotta put
these on the screens we gotta get them
in in the show and you've got to see in
the trailer we just put out
um Ashley Johnson plays Ellie's mom and
that was one of those stories that was
very near and dear to my heart and I'm
so glad it finally like gets to live oh
I love that uh Meryl I will say uh I
actually have listened to you and the
character embodies so much of your
physical uh representation as well but I
know that when you put on the wig from
what I heard from Craig it was a real
emotional moment for you because
although you voiced this character for
literally you know several several years
going on almost a decade that was the
first time you felt in it is that true
yeah well you know and I will take one
more step back which was my costume
fitting which
um as soon as I walked in I was I you
know saw the the mood boards and I saw
the choices and and was not prepared for
how I was going to feel when I actually
put the clothes on for the first time
and it just felt like worlds colliding I
was like what's happening Nia look at
this picture I don't know what's going
on I was it was really
um an unbelievable moment and then to
step you know even further and um you
know yes put on the wig and and and see
the the the full
situation the uh completely fleshed out
in front of my eyes was remarkable
because I've been on such a long
emotional connected Journey with her for
a decade now again there's so many
moments I think of I'm just thinking of
like some of the mocap bloopers that you
guys have done singing and all kinds of
stuff I'm like I've gotten all the
Easter eggs but in the end it's still no
matter whether it's the game or the TV
show it's these two characters and I
would say for both of you seeing another
person reimagine what these characters
are it's almost maybe an uncanny valley
what was something Neil that you saw
watching Bella and Pedro's
interpretations of the characters that
maybe felt brand new to you I'd be
really excited to see something that
they brought that you hadn't seen before
yeah it's such a privilege you know I
get to work with such amazing artists
and you know give them this material
that
um is inspiring them and they get to
interpret it they get to internalize it
it and then we get to see what comes out
on the other side that
uh
it's hard maybe to articulate those
differences there's definitely
differences but like
like Pedro is so charming and he has to
suppress all that when he's Joel and
then you get to see these moments where
he like kind of peeks out and when he
smiles
several episodes later it feels like a
set piece like an action like it's such
a reward for like people that have
invested a time in this relationship
likewise with with Bella
uh like I feel like we you know we got
lucky twice with this with this with
these casts of like Ashley Johnson was
able to capture Ellie so well and then
you have another person that's
interpreting them and at first like
there's a resistance like there's a fear
that they're not going to do as good of
a job or it's going to be too different
and I just my mind just keeps going back
to you know I was my Batman was the Tim
Burton Batman and I think of Jack
Nicholson as the Joker I'm like in my
mind that is the Joker and I remember
when I heard like Heath Ledger was cast
as a joke there's no way in hell Heath
Ledger is going to do as good of a job
as Jack Nicholson and he did it was
different and they were both the Joker
and that's kind of like how beauti is
it's like Ashley Johnson is Ellie
and Bella Ramsey as Ellie
um and it really kind of like now
there's like a clear separation it's
almost like I can see two dimensions and
they're both really true and honest as
those characters
you've come this far
and you know what's out there
you're not gonna scare us
scared who
Craig uh congratulations on the show as
a fan of both the uh video game and now
this you should be so incredibly proud
but I would say having watched this and
also having watched True Noble let me
just say you really love people in
Desperate situations I do
so is that what brought you into this or
were you I would love to love the idea
of you just being like playing the game
being like you know this might make a
good show that's exactly what happened I
mean I do love people in Desperate
situations I think desperate situations
show us who we really are but what what
happened was exactly the way you put it
it's 2013 I'm sitting on my couch I'm
like uh all right I'll play this game
it's got monsters whatever and I get
through the first 10 minutes I'm stunned
and I'm crying and I don't understand
what just happened and then that just
carries through and I was just I was
obsessed and I I actually remember
feeling sad that I was probably never
going to get a chance to like make a
Last of Us show you know and like meet
Neil and work and then here I am now
like
what a dream come true you know for a
fan it's it's so it's so funny thing to
you because I list
podcast for Chernobyl and
then out in some respect or the more
recent work I should say yeah uh but I
maybe I don't know maybe it's after you
go through the trials and tribulation of
a show like this because adapting a
video game is already a hard thing to do
and then when it's a game that you know
arguably people say is like the best
video game ever like was that it the
idea of bringing it to a new audience
like like what was the the main draw
once you actually started adapting it
through well I think initially what I
was just driven by was how much I loved
it but also I could see how
The Last of Us the the game experience
was kind of begging to to be this other
version you know I loved playing the
game but it you could see how it was
almost like wanted to be a television
show a little bit you know and thinking
about how to do that was so exciting and
doing it with Neil was the best because
Neil was incredibly flexible and brave
and and had no problem like stress
testing everything and how could we make
it better and how could we expand it but
also I knew like I was never going to be
able to do anything that like broke the
last of us because I got druckman next
to me that's not happening so you know
the two of us were like this together
the whole way through and just like I
don't know it was just a joy to fill
that world out and and give everybody
the things that I would desperately want
to see and then more
I love how it was the two of you really
sort of locked in behind the scenes
because obviously we know the last of us
it's right there from the you know the
the game poster the game cover now also
the cover of this one what was the
dynamic between Pedro and Bella that you
saw that you really wanted to translate
to the game because there's a lot that
you could play up with these characters
and even I would even say how you cast
them in this version well we were
looking for people that we felt just
embodied the soul of Joel and Ellie and
we got those people for sure we had no
question about that but then it was sort
of like well but what will they be like
together and that's where kind of luck
happens because they
bonded so fast and so profoundly I mean
they are like a unit you couldn't tear
them apart if you tried they love each
other and and and we love them you know
we wanted
to replicate for everybody whether they
had played the game or not the
experience of a man who was closed off
and broken
just opening up even you didn't even
realize it's happening opening up and
letting this love back in which is a
dangerous thing to do and we also wanted
to feel the ache of this girl who is
lonely and lost and has never had a
family has never had belonging and has
never been protected or cared about like
this we wanted to see that coming
through and they just delivered it in
the most beautiful way playing The Last
of Us means you're gonna cry watching
The Last of Us means you're gonna cry
but it it kind of feels good
you know it kind of feels good it's just
because Pedro and Bella made it true and
and what else can I ask for is somebody
making a television show
wow I mean I love what they did
obviously they made it so authentic but
before I get out of here I couldn't not
talk about Troy and obviously Ash let me
it's just the fact that you guys were
able to bring them into this and then
like have uh that Dynamic be a part of
this at this you know however many years
later but also especially with
particularly with Troy but with both of
them they've become such icons in the
video voice game world it's almost weird
seeing them not the way we all right
yeah
what was that like for you Troy's Troy
is the really weird one because he's
been 400 people and he looks like none
of them as far as I'm concerned there is
like you can see Ashley's face and Ellie
particularly in the new versions of
Ellie
um I mean obviously I'm deeply connected
to their performances I love them and
they're both just the most beautiful
people and I loved having them on set
and and their their eyes looking around
I mean remember Troy walking around
going oh my God I'm in it it was so like
moving for them and and don't forget
Merle Dandridge who plays Marlene she's
the one person who was the same
character in the game and in the show
Marlene has this great kind of like gray
streaked hair but Merle her hair is
perfect so you know we're working with a
wig she gets this wig on and just starts
bawling just instantly because she's
like it's I'm Marlene I'm it just
happened you like so having those
touchstones of people that did the game
and and were with us and working the
show and telling us that we were getting
it right and that we had casts well and
that Bella was amazing and Pedro was
amazing it just meant everything to me
everything
[Music]
could have ever imagined
careful who you put your faith in
[Music]
you might not be her father she was
someone's
one thing I will say is look Tess is a
bona fide like action hero uh in her own
right is that something that really Drew
you towards it like this sort of shade
of it because man you guys really take
it in the series
yeah of course that and working with
Pedro Pascal
um yeah it's always fun and you kind of
because I'm not really like that but um
I'm always surprised at how I'm like oh
like I'm shocked when I go oh I buy that
I see myself doing something like well I
bought that like well done yeah
yeah they make me look good yeah they do
all this stuff I don't really have to do
anything but I mean you are you I will
say this you are believable in it
outside of every moment so I will take
that all to you but if you want to make
it a team effort make it a team effort
uh one thing that is not is is a dual
effort is your Chemistry with Pedro and
just the whole test Joel of it all if we
will go ahead and say it for those of us
that are fans of the book
um how did you guys talk about that part
of it I mean obviously it seems like he
was part of that was the draw but then
you also have to like work it out and
there's the actual getting it done and
what you see maybe in chemistry tests
has to then translate on screen well
yeah we talked about it and and actually
the first scene that we shot was the
first scene that they were together and
there's not really that many moments but
we were adamant
um Pedro and I that we wanted I mean I
would have liked to have made it I would
have liked to have gone further but but
part of it is that you've got to be true
to the characters and um and we just
went I we both wanted them to we wanted
them to have been together for a long
time we wanted them to like be
incredibly loyal to each other we wanted
them to be in a relationship in a
partnership but as Tess and Joel like
not it's it's Tess and Joel in a
relationship and a partnership and then
we went well how do we do it and you go
because you don't want to over
you don't want to overdo stuff too
because
exactly and it's sort of like when you
when you agree on all of that stuff and
you you know you're just a there's an
ease between them and the first time you
see them Tess walks in the door
jumps into bed with him he rolls over
she puts her arm around and it's like
that's you know then like the audience
goes oh
one of the things we got from the
trailer is this epic clicking scene
which I again even if you weren't me
obsessed with the video games you have
to know just how incredible that scene
is can you talk about sort of working up
the choreographer the choreography for
that one because yes I know you guys
have brilliant stunt performers but
there's still a lot that goes into
everything before or after and sometimes
during those those moments
oh look uh then that was all
choreographed and then we came in and
and did it but I mean it was creepy
because the actors playing um the
clickers that's all them like the um the
disjointed kind of like the the
physicality of them they had practiced
and they did it for day like that was
them and also that
like all the sounds that was all them in
the room and so that was my first
experience of a clicker and so that was
frightening so that was all prosthetic
most of that's prosthetic and then these
really big tall beautiful like
unbelievably like just the just the the
movement was nuts they'd worked on it
they were amazing and then the sounds
all of the sounds was them
in the minute so it was frightening it
was really scary probably not hard to
stay in character in a moment like that
because again they're terrifying and
it's just where we're looking at it on
screen well then you didn't really want
to talk to any of them so you didn't
make like I that we only met them out of
the prosthetic like one time and then
you kind of wanted like hi like you just
didn't want to look well but incredible
they were in that for days I love it um
last question here real quick because I
will say this it's I guess scary in a
good way scary how talented they are at
their age but I will say uh Bella is
just absolutely incredible in this and I
know that if there is any Dynamic that
folks are more interested in than the
Joel and Tess it's obviously what Bella
and Pedro are doing with that with their
characters with Ellie and with Joel talk
about your chance to work with them and
what Bella brings to the table as a
young performer oh it was really fun I'm
sure she'd say the same thing too
because I'm money in just the beginning
of it and it's just Bella and Pedro and
so Pedro and I had worked together and
it was kind of we got to do it almost
chronologically so we kind of like had
this thing and then it was really
different all of a sudden Bella came in
and we were like oh this is a different
vibe and then in the same way it happens
with the thing Bella and I started to
really get on and get the giggles
together and by the end like we really
all we cracked each other up a lot and I
think partly part of it was because we
were you know just it was just
everything was so serious all the time
and you're constantly looking at this
revolting fungus everywhere and like
everything that we would you just would
and one of us would go and then the
other would go I mean the crew would be
like come on a lot of days that's okay
well I think it reads I think it reads
that we'll get you trust me
I'm so excited to talk to you because I
know you actually played the game so I'm
I'm also a fan of the game well I just
have to ask as a fan of the game knowing
that you were signing on to this besides
the daunting task of doing everything
you could with Tommy was there anything
you in particular were looking forward
to like Easter egg type stuff you were
like okay this is gonna be cool when we
do it yeah yeah absolutely there was I I
um I wanted to see how we were going to
recreate Austin Texas in Calgary Alberta
Canada because I'm from Austin and so I
was really thrilled to see what we were
going to do in terms of the production
design to bring my entire home
up north to Calgary and it didn't
disappoint I mean there was not only did
it match uh my experience and my what I
know to be the authentic elements of my
hometown but it also matched the game in
a really incredible way so I was all
over the place taking pictures of uh
you know movie posters or or
um you know certain buildings and
certain kind of architecture structures
that
all of the Texas Longhorn paraphernalia
that was everywhere so I think
that's what I was looking forward to and
it didn't disappoint I really love that
I also love the Austin Texas shout out
I'm I'm also I'm not an austinborn but I
was Austin Brad I went to school there
and lived there many years so I'm I also
will say they did a very incredible job
which is incredible desolate Austin but
one of the things you did have to sort
of create in whole cloth for this series
is the bond between Tommy and Joel with
your bomb with Pedro and I know that you
guys had a fun set but again sort of
playing Brothers in this the dynamic
between these characters in the game is
interesting and you kind of like have to
make that translate on the series or did
you guys want to explore it completely
different well we were and we had
different entry points because I knew
the game I knew the whole story I knew
the experience he had uh he had watched
a lot of the playthroughs and a lot of
the cinematics on YouTube so he was
familiar with it
[Music]
um
so we uh but what we were dealing with
was uh superbly crafted script that
Craig and Neil
you know laid in front of us
we just we need only stay true to the
story and how he was unfolding in this
grid I mean a lot of the way that they
the their their
the Tit for Tat that Brothers
you know that that brothers are apt to
kind of engage in was there in the
script and I know it very well because
me and my brother only 22 months apart
and we used to always you know knock
heads
so all of that was very very uh easy to
slip into because it was written written
so well but beyond that he and I both
Pedro and I were both raised in Texas he
was born in Chile raised in San Antonio
I was raised in Austin we just we just
thought that it was important that we
just draw on that and lean into it and
allow it to uh inform our relationship
and it did and it did in a very it
gelled in a very uh in a very quick way
which was important because we when we
were when we were off and running we
were certainly off and running so uh I
just uh yeah I couldn't have asked for a
better obscene partner until he's so
giving and so playful and and uh
immensely talented
the other thing I would really ask since
you were definitely somebody that had
the full experience of playing the game
and really living in that is you were
probably a little bit like the you know
on set if you can't grab the technical
advisor ask Gabriel that was it you're
right about that um did you put a lot of
that expertise into the clicker scene
because that has that's a that's a
moment in the game that is just
literally instructive so so much just
learning how to deal with them like that
first attack from them is like one of
the scariest moments in the game uh Did
you sort of like Circle that day and
really sort of pay attention to how they
they translated that as a gamer did you
just let yourself be a gamer for a day
with that moment you know we um you you
kind of prepare for it and you know
which which parts of the script are are
married to the game that you really love
you're like excited okay I'm gonna can't
wait for this and and but then you get
there and and you just forget all about
that and your preconception of what it
was going to be because of how
you know it's it becomes uh it becomes
what happens what happened with me Pedro
Nico what just happened in a moment
and you're not really too concerned
about uh applying it point for Point
you're you're really just
everything is there it's constructed in
a way that honors the game and and uh if
you live in the moment honestly it'll
you'll you'll have contributed the
important part that you need to bring
and um and so that was uh that was yeah
that was kind of effortless but the but
you're right no I was I was always
called on to be uh a bit of a technical
consultant when it came to the game a
Pedro turned to me a lot is like is this
what happens in the games itself it's
like no dude this is exactly how it
happens in the game or or no we're doing
this differently you know I really
appreciate that
um one thing that for at least when I
saw I didn't get to see there's lots of
solo episodes and I didn't get to a
Tommy solo episode so are we gonna get
one this time do you know can you teach
you have to watch and see yeah oh come
on I see they taught you well they
taught you well